مشاهدينا الكرام قبل اقل من اسبوعين اصدرت
جماعه الامريكيه العريقه تقريبا مكونا من
34 صفحه مفاده ان الحكومه الروسيه تحتجز
حاليا نحو سته الاف طفل اوكراني تتراوح
اعمارهم من اربعه اشهر الى 17 عاما في
ثلاثه واربعين معسكررا تدريبيا في روسيا
وفي شبه جزيره القرم بهدف اطفاء الصبغه
وثقافه الروسيه في المناطق الاوكرانيه
المحتله من خلال برامج تعليميه روسيه
ممنهجه لهؤلاء الاطفال
الاداره الامريكيه تبنت التقرير واعتبرتهم
من بين اهم الادله على ارتكاب روسيا
لجرائم ضد الانسانيه في اوكرانيا
وتطرقت اليه ولينا زوجه الرئيس الاوكراني
كلمه لها في الامم المتحده كما فعل ذلك
المدعي العام للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
ووزير خارجيته اوكرانيا
البروفيسور ان ثانيه
دعي الى الامم المتحده للحديث عن تقريره
ومناقشته ويجلس الينا حصريا الان لمناقشه
هذا التقرير المثيري للجدل
وفسر ثانيا البروفيسور نتانيا
المدير التنفيذي
لمختبراتي الابحاث الانسانيه والمحاضر في
جامعه
الامريكيه في كليه الصحه نرحب بكم في
قناتي العربيه والحدث من دواعي سروري ان
اكون معكم طلال اود ان ابدا بالحديث عن
تقريركم من منظوري ردود الافعال التي
لاحظتموها بشان هذا التقرير المهم
والذي كان الى حد ما موضع جدل
باختصار كانت ردود فعل مهوله منذ صدور هذا
التقرير والاشاره اليه من قبل رئيس
الولايات المتحده في كلمته في وارسو وذكر
فيها ان روسيا تصرخ الاطفال في اوكرانيا
من اجل زرقه مستقبل اوكرانيا كذلك اشارت
نائبه الرئيس الامريكي حول الادله في
التقرير من خلال تصريحاتها عن جرائم الحرب
ضد الانسانيه والاعلان عن تصنيف الولايات
المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي ومعاقبه
المسؤولين الضلعين فالانشطه الوارده ذكرها
في التقرير بمن فيهم الرئيس بوتين بنفسه
هو ماريا لافوفا بيلوفا رئيسه البرنامج اذ
وردت الاشاره اليهم بصوره اساسيه بعد 48
ساعه من صدور التقرير بانهم يوسعون نطاق
تدريب الشباب الاوكرانيين والروس ضمن
الفئه العمريه 17 عاما بما ذلك في الشيشان
يشير التقرير الى ان ما يزيد عن سته الاف
طفلا من اوكرانيا قد خضعوا لهذا النظام
خلال سنه الحرب الماضيه بطبيعه الحال لكن
التقرير يذكر ان الاعداد الحقيقيه ويرجح
ان تكون اعلى بكثير ما استطيع قوله انه
يحتمل انها المره الاولى التي يكون لدينا
فيها عشرات المواقع الاضافيه التي تخضع
للتحقيق في الفتره الحاليه اذ نحققه في
فيما يصل الى 30 موقعا اضافيا خلافه
المواقع الثلاثه والاربعين المذكوره في
تقرير نعتقد ان العدد 6000 طفل الذي قد
الان
بما يصل الى 15 الف طفلا وهو الرقم الذي
صدر عن الحكومه الاوكرانيه وهذا الرقم سوف
يستمر في الصعود في الايام المقبله ماذا
تقولونه للحكومه الروسيه التي تحاجج بان
هؤلاء الاطفال قد تم انقاذهم من قبل روس
اطفال اوكرانيون تم هجرانهم من قبل اولياء
امورهم وتركوا ليدافعوا انفسهم في هذه
الحرب ماذا تقول بشان ذلك ما اقوله لروسيا
اقراوا معاهده جنيف التي انتم طرفا فيها
يحضروا ميثاق جنيفر صراحه اخذ الاطفال من
بلد تكون طرفا في صراعا مع طرف اخر ويذكره
على وجه التحديد بانه يتواجد نقلهم الى
بلد ثالث بالاضافه الى ذلك يجب التسجيل
الاطفال وسماح لهم بالاتصال بموطنهم
وسماحل لمراقبين الدوليين بزيارتهم في
الفتره الحاليه وبصرف النظر عن اي
اقتباسات للمهمه الانسانيه التي تتحدث
عنها
فانهم خالف القانون باختصار لكن الروسي
يبدو بانهم فخورين يبدو ان الحكومه
الروسيه فخوره بالبرنامج الذي تعمل على
توسيع النطاقه في حقيقه مئه في المئه طلال
عليك ان تدرك بان الجمهور الحقيقي لهذا
البرنامج هو جمهور محلي روسي وهذا جزء من
جهود واسعه النطاق من اجل اعاده تسميه
روايه الغزو على انها ترمي لانقاذ اطفال
اوكرانيا حقيقه الامر هي بانهم يسمونه
نجاحا على الصعيد الانساني لما يزعموا انه
جريمه حرب يحتمل ان يكون جريمه ضد
الانسانيه تتهم وزاره الخارجيه ورئيس
الولايات المتحده الان روسيا بارتكاب
جرائم ضد الانسانيه وهي واحده من الجرائم
الكبرى التي انشات المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه من اجلها هل تسميه الروس
بارتكابهم لجرائم ضد الانسانيه هو ما
ارتكز عليه تقري بني بسوره جزئيه على
تقريرنا لكنه ايضا على اجمالي الادله التي
تم جمعها السنه الماضيه حول التصرفات التي
تتراوح ما بين الهجمات الممنهجه على
المنشات المدنيه مستشفيات ومدارس ومحطات
قطارات وادله واضحه عن استخدام الاغتصاب
كسلاح حرب واعدام المدنيين في اماكن مثل
بوتشا
هل قامت وزاره الخارجيه قبل قبول
تقريركم وفي سياق
البحث عن الادله لتسميه روسيا على
ارتكابها جرائم ضد الانسانيه هل تحققت
وزاره الخارجيه من المعلومات الوارده في
تقريركم لقد انخرطنا في عمليه فحص مطول مع
وزاره الخارجيه ولم يتم الافصاح عنها حتى
اعتقدت وزاره الخارجيه باننا تجاوزنا
الحدود المسموح بها واود ان اكون واضحا
للغايه هنا فقد كنا محافظين الى حد ما في
هذا التقرير او قد لكننا تركنا معلومات
كثيره لم يتم ذكرها وفي الواقع ساقول انهم
مع مرور الوقت فان تقريرنا سيبدو شديده
تحفظ مقارنه بالارقام الفعليه التي نتحدث
عنها
كان الهدف من هذا التقرير هو تقديم الادله
الدامغه والتي لا يمكن ضهدها
بشان مدى دقتها وشرعيتها طالما ان هؤلاء
الاطفال موجودون في عهده روسيا دون مراعاه
الاخيره بعد الاتفاقيه حقوق الطفل
واتفاقيه الجنيف يتعين اذا علينا التعامل
معهم على انهم راها حتى يتمكنوا من
الاتصال بابائهم وامهاتهم والقول اننا هنا
نستطيع العوده لما فانه يتم استخدام لكافه
النوايا والاغراض واستخدامهم كاوراق رهائن
في لعبه خطيره لو نقلت روسيا هؤلاء
الاطفال الى بلد ثالث هل سيكون الوضع
مختلفا نعم سوف يكون
ملتزمين بالقانون ولو اخذوهم الى بلد ثالث
ثم قاموا بتسجيلهم وسمح لهم بالوصول الى
الهواتف التي لا يمتلكونها حاليا ومن ثم
السماح للصليب الاحمر او الامم المتحده او
المنظمات المستقله
للتحقق من رفاههم واعادت لم شملهم مع عسر
فنعم فهذا ما يجب ان تفعله في روسيا هل لك
ان تخبرنا من بحوثك كيف يعمل هذا البرنامج
انا سعيد حقا لانك طرحت هذا السؤال لذا
ومن اجل مشاهديكم الكرام اود ان اشير الى
مجموعتين من الاطفال المجموعه الاولى هي
من هؤلاء الاطفال الذين ينحذرون من الاصل
من دونهم غالبيه العدد البالغ سته وهم من
الاطفال الذين اباؤهم في كثير من الاحيان
من المعلمين او زعماء مجالس قرويه قيل لهم
بانهم يكونوا الحصول على الاجازات مجانيه
اذا ما ارسلوا اطفالهم القتال رغم رفض
ابائهم لذلك يذهب الاطفال الى هذه
المعسكرات وليعودون ابدا الى المنزل هذه
مجموعه واحده رجع البعض منهم والبعض الاخر
قد تم اعادتهم قبل الاباء الذين اضطروا
للذهاب في رحله خطيره وقد شاهدنا في
الايام القليله الماضيه عن بعض الاهالي
الذين اضطروا التوجه في
من اجل لمس شمله اطفالهم والمجموعه
الثانيه يطلقوا يسمونهم اولئك من تموا
اجلائهم وهم الخرق كيف
كان هؤلاء الاطفال في مؤسسات الدوله
الاوكرانيه ابان الغزو قبل عام تقريبا من
هذا الاسبوع طلال وفي احدى الحالات يوجد
اطفال من ذوي الاعاقه في احدى المنشات وتم
نقلهم من قبل للقوات الروسيه من تلك
المؤسسات الحكوميه الى روسيا وعمليات
التبني
وكفاله هذه الاطفال نراها في الغالب من
المجموعه الثانيه الذين تم اجلهم والاشخاص
الذين تم اجلائهم وهذان المعسكران وهما
موضع بحثنا في نظام اعاده التعليمي تم اخذ
الاطفال للتبني والكفاله
هل نعلم هويتي هؤلاء الاشخاص الروس
المسؤولين عن تنفيذ هذا البرنامج والاشراف
عليه نعم لقد حددنا 12 فردا يخضعون الان
للعقوبات الامريكيه
والعقوبات الدوليه في وقت صدور التقرير
الذي يبدو سيكون اساسيا في البرنامج بما
في ذلك اربع حكام اقليميه والاهم من ذلك
في قمه القياده والسيطره توجد امراه اسمها
ماريا لوفا بيلوبا وهي مفوضه حقوق الاطفال
بعد صدور التقرير شاركت الاخيره الرئيس
بوتين في مؤتمر صحفي في الكرملي حيث تحدثت
عن نفسها انها تبنت طفلا يبلغ من العمر 15
عاما من دومباس وقالت الان اعرف ما الذي
يعنيه ان تكون اما في دومبر يبدو ان ماريا
لوفوفا بلوفا مسؤوله عن الاشراف على
البرنامج الاكبر ولكن هذا يمثل نقطه حرجه
فهناك نوع من البرامج المخ التي تجري هناك
حيث يقوم عمد البلديات والحكام واقتبسوا
هنا برعايه البلدات في اوكرانيا والدفع
لقاء جلب هؤلاء الاطفال الى روسيا ومصدر
معلوماتنا الحساس لهذا التقرير نبع من
تصريحات لمسؤولين روزا بانفسهم مراقبه
الرسائل التواصل الاجتماعي من هؤلاء
المسؤولين المحليين حيث قاموا بشكل اساسي
بالترويج والتهليل للانتقال للاطفال الى
هذه المعسكرات ورسائلهم هذا ما ما نحن حقا
النافذه للبدء بمساله تحديد الموقع
الجغرافي ومواقع المعسكرات التي تمتد من
البحر في القرن المحتله الى سيبيريا
ووصولا الى شرق المحيط الهادئ وهي اقرب
الى اليابان الاسكا من اوكرانيا
ماذا نتوقع من وزاره الخارجيه وما هي
الخطوات التاليه بعد اعتماد
هذا التقرير
واستخدامه
كطريقه لتوثيق
التكلفه
البشريه
والجرائم الدوليه ضد الانسانيه
ما هي الخطوه التاليه سوف اخبرك بما رايته
سلفا وهو امر
يجدر مشاهدته ما نراه وسبب وجودي في الامم
المتحده اليوم هو بصوره اساسيه تقديم
وتوصيات حول ما يجب ان يحدث بعد ذلك هذا
ما ارى نرى ان الاتحاد الاوروبي يتبنى
عقوبات ضد الافراد المتورطين في هذا
البرنامج واعتقد انه من المحتمل ان تتخذ
الدول الاخرى مسارا مشابها وامل ان يفعل
ذلك ونرى ايضا ضغطا متزايدا
لنظام تسجيل دولي موحد لهؤلاء الاطفال لذا
اعتقد ان السؤال الذي يجب طرحه على وزاره
الخارجيه هو ما يحدث على صعيد تلك
العقوبات اولا وما يحدث بخصوص الضغوط من
اجل تبني النظام تسجيل واعتقد انه يجب ان
يطرح هذا السؤال على كل دوله عضو في الامم
المتحده ما تفعلونه
لضمان محاسبه هؤلاء الضالعين في سلسله
المسؤوليه القياديه كما يجب علينا ان
نتاكد من قدرتنا على احصاء هؤلاء الاطفال
ومعرفه كم هو العدد الذي نتعامل معه تم
انجاز الكثير من العمل في هذا التقرير
والبحث هل يمكنك اعطائنا وانا افهم مدى
الخصوصيه والسريه في مثل هذه الحالات لكن
هل يمكنك اخبارنا بشيء عن اعضاء فريق
العمل الان
وعددهم اماكن تواجدهم وانا متاكد من انها
ليست وظيفه رجل واحد لكن هل بمقدورك ان
تشاطرا بعض المعلومات حول فريق العمل
الخاص بكم حسنا الرجال والنساء في فريقنا
هم الابطال الحقيقيون هنا انا فقط الوجه
العام ولكن في نهايه العام انهم المتخصصون
في التصوير واخصائي المصادر المفتوحه
واخصائي اللغه هم الذين عملوا لاكثر من
سته اشهر على مدار الساعه اتمنى لو
موجودين لانهم موضع اهتماما اكثر مني
لكنهم حققوا ذلك من اجل حمايه الاطفال لا
يمكنهم ان نقول الكثير عن عددهم او من هم
ولكنهم هم الاشخاص الذين حققوا ذلك
الانجاز
في الواقع يمثل تواجدكم هنا في الامم
المتحده اليوم
والتحدث الى الدول الاعضاء
خير دليل على تبني واعتماد تقريركم
وشهادتكم لما لهما من مصداقيه واهميه
بالغه اشيد بعملكم الجاد واتمنى لكم حظا
وافرا واود صراحه ان اهنئك حقيقه على
التقرير لانه كان
نجاحا باهرا لاي باحث لا يتم تبنيه فقط من
قبل وزير الخارجيه بل من قبل رئيس
الولايات المتحده ونائبه الرئيس والان
الامم المتحده تعقد اجتماعات لمناقشه
محتوى تقريركم احسنتم واشكركم بالغ الشكر
على مجيئكم للتحدث الينا شكرا شكرا